[Music]
so identity theft is a thing parent all
parental theft is a thing huh who knew
who know Jesus come quickly I mean
really Wow
you steal from your own kids you open
credit cards in your kids names steal
their identity let me just help you with
this that's criminal fraud it's robbing
a bank and sadly there's there's two
types of identity theft we all know
about like Yahoo with 3 billion accounts
we know Equifax is a total bunch of
incompetence 143 million accounts
dropped out there on Equifax right we
all know and and just this week they got
1 another 5 million or something poured
out that they came out with and you know
people steal your you know that they got
the magnetic stripes or whatever in the
in the ATMs they steal your stuff they
look over your shoulder they whatever
you know there's the classic crooks that
basically don't know you and they live
in whatever you know some country or
something Siberia or whatever and
they're sitting at their little laptop
just pecking away in the underlings of
the Internet and the you know the like
some scene from the Lord of the Rings or
something and they're just popping out
you know they're stealing the identity
but you know what Sandling a lot of
identity theft is people you know
somebody you know and the amount of
parents that are scum that would steal
from their own children and let me help
you with this if you're stealing from
your children by definition you're scum
you look up scum in the dictionary your
pictures right there I mean it's just
it's pretty easy to identify I'm not
just calling you names I'm giving you a
definition here okay so I mean really
that's just the bottom of the barrel but
you know it's not only a financial fraud
right these days there's medical fraud
tax fraud they'll sign up and get your
tax refund sent to them these crooks
sometimes as people you know sometimes
it's a traditional crook steal your
social security number and steal your
Social Security check
then have it redirected and sent to
their
account most social security checks are
direct deposit by the way if you didn't
know that you know the employment fraud
that people actually get jobs in other
people's names I mean that's how bad
some companies are at actually checking
the documentation of the people that go
to work for them of course you can buy
stuff in someone else's name and you
know illegally this identity theft thing
is far far reaching and you know many
many years ago I started talking on my
friends jobs and Rovers and ER insurance
and said dude you got to put together a
product to cover this because you know
these you hear these highly advertised
identity theft protection places they're
not identity theft protection ok there's
not a lot of protection you can do I
mean there's some stuff you can do you
can freeze your credit bureau report you
can limit the use of some of your places
you use a card don't go on unsecured
sites there's some stuff you can do but
it doesn't matter it went when most
Americans have now had their identity
stolen it's only a matter of time
whether somebody's gonna open an account
in your name that's the only question
whether it's going to show up with it
you know minimum I mean like I carry a
couple debit cards on any credit cards
and I look up and there's charges in
Mexico well I am a been in Mexico so I'm
apparently that and I didn't order
anything from Mexico so apparently that
wasn't me so we turned those charges
over and while I I get a new debit card
in the mail a couple days later and they
shut down the account then shut down the
card and start over right the algorithms
in these places catch most of it but we
also catch weird charges coming through
our statements as we actually look at
our statements which is something by the
way you ought to do you know to actually
look at your statements it's called
managing your money because you'll see
stuff on there you go what is that and
what you'll do is you'll realize you're
spending money you shouldn't be spending
or somebody stole your identity right so
here's the thing if someone takes your
social security number in your name and
opens an account in your name you're not
liable one time my wife is parked at the
YMCA and a crook professional crook well
not professional remember the idiot and
the woman
she was really stupid took him about
three days to catch her it was all but
she threw a brick through the window of
my wife's car and picked the purse up
out of the seat not sure and shouldn't
left person to see she's asking for it
okay but she did so she gets her purse
stolen I mean in 45 minutes this woman
had already written checks at several
places that accepted the checks
she bought $400 worth of stuff at a
grocery store signed my wife's name to
it they apparently didn't check ID
because I can promise you this woman did
not look like Sharon she was a
considerably different in every possible
way so it was not Sharon we know that
and so the cameras cameras disclosed
that right so guess who gets to pay that
check woman signed my wife's name and
put a fraudulent check on the table at
the grocery store they accepted the
check because they didn't check ID and
the four hundred others are we liable is
Sharon liable for that check absolutely
not
the crook stole her checks grocery-store
didn't do a good job checking IDs the
grocery store loses that money it was
stolen from them my wife's stolen checks
were used as the vehicle to do it but it
didn't cost us any money we didn't have
to go over to the grocery store make
good on the check by that
same things true if your identity stolen
someone opens a credit card in your name
and goes and runs up that credit card
you didn't do it they don't have any
kind of legal authorization from you to
do that you are not liable that is not
the problem with identity theft is the
liability of it the problem with
identity theft is you have to call an
idiot credit card company and actually
explain to them that it's not you and
the first thing they think is you just
don't want pay your bill so you get
transferred to the fraud-victim division
of a credit card company talk about a
bunch of winners and you get to go
through bureaucracy hell trying to get
these people to actually remove this
charge from your credit card or your
debit card because it is not you and you
end up having to file a police report
signed multiple notarized affidavits you
have to go through
all kinds of crap and it's it's
estimated that 600 hours worth of work
to get your identity cleanse that once
it's been stolen and utilized to open
accounts this is cold total pain in the
butt because people you're dealing with
on the other end don't give her up
they don't care your whole life is
untangled but they don't care so when I
was talking to Jeff Zander I said look I
don't want some fraud alert too late
then which is fine to get a fraud alert
from your identity theft protection
company that's fine
get a fraud alert somebody's messing
with your credit good get a fraud alert
by then it's too late though they've
already opened six accounts in your name
that's not the problem the problem is
all the time it takes to clean it up and
so this is and our insurance identity
theft protection actually assign someone
that goes and does all the work for you
now we got something you have a
caseworker assigned that a certified
specialist that goes and does all the
work for you and they have a 100%
success rate in recovering any lost
funds so you need someone that does that
that's what you need so if you're going
to buy identity theft protection and you
should because that young men calling a
few minutes ago is just part of the deal
right now obviously you can't turn that
in if you turn it into this identity
theft company for them to do resolution
I think criminals will be prosecuted
including the ones in your family so you
need to keep that in mind but some of
the identity theft protection companies
won't work a family deal even if you're
willing to point the finger and go
so-and-so's crook mom is a crook so
actually they actually have wallet
protection they replace the contents of
your wallet if it's lost or stolen when
you do this and or thing so you need
someone assigned to do the work for you
and you need to make sure that you're
doing all the stuff you get the fraud
alerts that's all fine but someone
that's not to do the work for you is the
big deal and somebody that's got you
know this 100% success rate and so be
sure you check that out oh and by the
way they cover your kids until age 18
for free on your plan a lot of
competitors don't do that this is not an
ad for Xander but I mean I just was
thinking about if they young
called a minute ago oh my gosh I've
heard had friends that there man
divorced situations where they fun
discover that the spouse has been
stealing the kids credit for years it's
just nasty out there y'all people are
just crazy
so you need identity theft protection I
recommend and always have it's the only
one I've ever recommended Xander
insurance be sure you check them out
Xander insurance com this is the Dave
Ramsey show